In this part of our material optimizations, I want to talk about material switches, as material switches allow you to do some pretty interesting things when it comes to enabling or disabling functionality and the materials you create.
Material switches can be broken up into the following three nodes. There's a static bool, a static switch, and a mask switch.
Now the static bool allows you to use the switch node and enable or disable entire branches of your material.
This can be really useful if you want to enable a certain type of functionality, but only inside of the material and not expose that to any material instances that might be created from this.
If you do need to expose anything inside your material to a material instance, that's where this static switch node comes in.
The static switch works in a similar manner to a static bool. It has a true and a false input.
But static switches can be utilized inside of material instances, and this will allow you to, again, enable bits of shader logic and disable bits of shader logic based on the needs of the material.
The last material switch, the mask switch, this allows you to adjust which channel is used inside of a texture.
The mask switch is generally used when you want to set up a material instance to work with an RGB-packed mask.
One last thing that I like to highlight about material switches is that they produce extra shader pre-mutation sets for each combination of settings.
This means if you've got two static switch parameters or four unique combinations, but you're only using two of those combinations in your material instances, then you end up compiling two sets of pre-mutations.
So, again, static switches, while they are useful, they can quickly create lots of shader pre-mutations, which can eat up shader compile time and cause slow editor loading and slow project loading.